normally a tower of hanoi looks like
three little spikes and you have
different discs on them the aim of the
game is to move the tower from one of
the spikes to another spike
[Music]
now i found that the spikes were holding
me back so i made this speed tower of
hanoi so that i can
i can get to it more quickly so you
can't put a bigger one on top of a
smaller one not allowed and you can only
move them one piece at a time so just
one piece at a time um
actually completing it with three is
really easy do you want to have a go so
first one i'm going to put it here
next one i'll move it over here
i'm it wouldn't do me any help to move
this back here so i'm gonna put this one
here
the bottom one moves that lets us know
we're halfway
one here
here
we've reformed a tower but it's in a new
position now so i'm gonna do one with
six pieces you do it with flare don't
you
[Laughter]
the only way i know how
so i've given each piece of the tower a
musical note uh lowest note is gonna be
the biggest piece and the highest note
is going to be the top smallest piece
there
[Music]
i think the cool thing about this is i
gave a key and so i decided the notes
but i didn't decide the order at all
this is the optimal solve and it's just
the music you're about to hear is made
by doing the optimal solve of the tower
of hanoi
let's do this
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
well done okay so i'll do it again and
you can see any patterns that you notice
coming up so tell me first of all what
you notice about the little piece so
this is how to solve the tower of hanoi
so we're going here
do you notice anything about the little
piece
where it's gone
it's like always going
from that side across to that side yeah
uh-huh so it follows a little a little
directional loop if you if you labeled
the positions a b c i think
that helps so we're going little pieces
on a now it's on b
now it's on c
back to a
now it's over to b
c that's one of two steps that you need
to know so the little piece is going to
move around going abc so you move the
little piece and then there's only one
other position that the next piece could
move to so this goes to here the little
piece you know is moving along and then
this one there's only one valid move
that you could make so it moves along
again um there's something as well that
you might notice about the two colors so
i've two colored this do you ever see
any of the same color touching
not that i've noticed no so that's
usually how i know if i've messed
something up
is i would have the same color touching
so there's a parody in the tower of
hanoi with the odd and even pieces so
the first one the small piece we'll call
that an odd one because it's the piece
one
and it's moving
from left to right from me is that right
to left for you yeah okay so it's moving
right to left the second one this one
here
you might want to look at where it's
going
so it's again
it's moving piecewise but just slower
than this top one and it goes from the
other direction all of the purple pieces
as i solve it they're moving in a little
cycle they're going a b c a b c and
these pastel cloud color pieces they are
moving the opposite direction so they'll
be going a
c b a c b the smaller pieces move faster
so this one actually every second move
is the smallest piece don't mean to stop
solving this now
it's like rubik's cube have you got a
record time oh right okay so we should
talk a little bit about the time because
this takes i'm working at 90 bpm so
this takes me roughly 30 seconds to
solve a six piece tower of hanoi but if
you were to add more pieces to it very
quickly gets out of hand should we go to
brown paper and calculator situation and
it discs the number of moves the amount
of time
90 beats per minute so one disc can be
completed in
one
move and
that took what
a second
less than a second
two discs and
one two
three moves
that would take two seconds three how
far shall we go four
so six that's how many we did
let's see if you can get the pattern for
the moves so that we don't have to solve
it every time um so here's three discs
how many moves is that going to take one
two three
four five six
seven i think that this should be enough
for you to see the pattern how many
moves it takes to do the optimal solve
it won't take me too long to do four one
two three
four
five six seven
eight
nine 10 11 12 13 14
15.
okay so the gap between them was two
four eight
is the next step going to be 16 yes
looking at the gaps is always a really
good thing to do when you're trying to
figure out patterns so we're going up
and we're doubling every time which
means we're going to have 2 to the power
of n but you've got to do a bit of an
adjustment because when n is 1
we don't have 2
so how are you going to fix that
take away 1.
um okay so we've got 2 to the power of n
minus 1 powers of 2 take away one and
that's the optimum solve that's your
quickest way of getting this solved 31
64. take away one is
63. okay
cool
right okay so that's the first 10 which
if you think about it would only be
this tall
so by the time you get to something
around this tall it's taking 11 minutes
to solve what number would you like what
should we check out we've done to 10. i
feel like i want to know a 100 100 is a
good one okay so 10 to the power of 30
moves okay and we're doing 90 of them in
a minute so let's divide that by 90.
okay so it's around about 2.6 times 10
to the power of 22
years yep so for a hundred stacks that
is how long it would take me to solve it
doing it musically at 90 bpm you know it
would fit in this room fine it could
logistically be done in this room i
don't have enough time for that
so when i'm solving the three block
optimal i go here and here and then my
next move following the algorithm would
be this one continues on its way but if
i wanted there's no rule against moving
this back here i still have a smaller
piece on a larger piece i'm moving one
at a time and then i could move this
here
and this here i mean it's not helping me
that much and this one could go here and
i know it's not optimal because i have
two odd pieces touching um i could then
move this one here for a while for no
reason
put this one here then it could go here
back to here
so there's a really cool way of showing
all of the different states all of the
possibilities of
laying out these disks onto the three
what would you call them
positions so let's call our three
positions a b and c and right now i'm
going from smallest to largest they're
all on position a so i'm going to call
this a a a
and from here i could move to baa if i
like
so that's an option that i have so the
first letter is where the baby one is
yeah so it goes small medium large
and large
so i could go to baa or
i could go to caa and from this position
here caa i could move back to baa so
we're happy to link those
so there's a nice little triangle
because all we're dealing with is the
first one right now you know could move
from this vertex here at baa
where can i go so
i've already covered caa i can then
start moving the middle one it can't go
here
that's not allowed but it could go here
this would be called
b
c a we're going small medium large b
c
a
okay from this vertex here back to there
caa
my options again kind of limited because
i'm moving the middle one now i can't
put it there there's only one move i can
make it has to go here and so that's
going to be called cba
from here bca where can we go let's have
a look
i can move the small one and i can give
myself a cca
and i could move the small one and go to
ac a
and if i were to move this one here and
what would that be that would be baa
which is going back up along the route
so we don't need to show that one so
it's only the small one moving that
makes sense here i've got my two options
a c a and i can swap between these two
as well
so i can put a line in there i think i
think once we fill in what can happen
here you might start to recognize
something
[Music]
when i've got them stacked up at this
aba position a b a i could move this one
if i want as well
and that's got a free space and that
would give me a c a which is already on
this graph so i can join those together
and at this point
you maybe start to notice what's going
on here
yeah you obviously i don't say that the
ever ubiquitous um it's totally
ubiquitous
[Laughter]
yeah we've got a sierpinski triangle
situation here
will i fill this in for the other
options
[Music]
bbb
[Music]
and that would be a solve so that's them
all stacked up in a different position
[Music]
so ccc that's a solve as well
and just the way that
a sierpinski triangle works
the size is going to be 2n so this
length here
will be
two to the power three which is eight
and um because you're already starting
on one you're already here so it only
takes you one two three four five six
seven and then you're at your solved
position so that that is where your two
n minus one comes from and i mean if you
wanted to take a really leisurely stroll
around the tower of hanoi you know
you're not in a rush to get from a to c
and solve it all there is a way to go
around every single one of them
so we're starting here we're going to go
along here
take a little detour into there
ccc so that's your longest route and
then if you want to go back to where you
started
okay
yeah so this is a cyclical way of
getting around all of the possible
positions in your tower of hanoi it's a
hamiltonian path and if you can see it
drawn out it's called the sierpinski
arrowhead i love it it's a beautiful
fractal
thanks to brilliant for supporting
today's episode
and what a ray of light brilliant is
with its interactive courses daily
challenges quizzes all sorts of great
stuff to expand your mind and keep you
entertained
everything's lovingly designed to make
sure you're engaged to keep your
thinking to keep you clever it's really
good looking
easy to use it's made by people who care
and who are serious about making the
world a better place
if you've already got it why not
consider brilliant as a gift for the
other curious minds in your life
there's even twenty percent off a
premium subscription by going to
brilliant.org
number five
the address there on the screen
check them out you will not be
disappointed
check out the links in the video
description we've got a bit of bonus
footage on our number file 2 channel
behind the scenes on the recording of
our tower of hanoi video and there are
also links to aliens work on social
media she's especially big on tick tock
i'm led to believe but she's doing
really great stuff so check it out